how many followers do you have on
Instagram I don't have an Instagram
I don't have any social media okay okay
your shoes are kind of beat
um I I don't like beat shoes I don't
mind your outfit I don't I don't like
mine the outfit like the shoes are a
little beat up but like a little
I actually need something oh my gosh
I was only thinking about appearance I
am cool with myself you have kids yeah
you're like the cool dad that's what you
are what
cool dad knock knock who's there Britney
Spears Britney Spears who
was there oops I Did It Again
I love you
thank you your purse
thank you
you're saying he's not cool I don't know
you're like a really nice person but I
feel like I'm kind of like embarrassed I
could do some more work right yeah